une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités mais aujourd'hui en fait il y a
pas d'invité parce qu'on est juste les
deux et on fait un Kyo année on a pris
vos questions
moi je suis dans une plante en passant
et ph41 on a pris vos questions et on y
répond on jette les deux de plein de
sujets vous avez demandé comment ça va
vous nous avez demandé
comment vous faites pour rester motivé à
vous entraîner ou à faire quelconque
activité des questions un petit peu plus
personnelles des questions sur la
société des questions sur pleine
affaires philosophique toutes sortes de
questions du plus banal ou plus donc
j'espère que vous allez aimer ça je
pense que on est super bonne
conversation encore une fois ma pH puis
bah bonne écoute sans plus attendre
voici le kiwani d'aujourd'hui
le podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
menscape vous savez au sans filtre
podcast on adore les produits mainscape
on les utilise littéralement à tous les
jours moi le body wash c'est toujours
dans ma douche
et les bien sûr les rasoirs les
tondeuses électriques que j'utilise
régulièrement aujourd'hui je vous parle
de quelques produits j'ai ici le wewer
2.0 ça c'est pour garder ce contrôle les
poils donnés les poils d'oreilles qui
pourraient dépasser moi que je tendance
à avoir des poils de nez un peu trop
long puis quand il dépasse ma blonde
attire dessus à mes arraches ça fait mal
faut absolument que je me porte avant et
aussi le beat ageor ici qui s'est
tondeuse électrique pour la barbe qui
est vraiment super efficace qui est
vraiment super simple à utiliser et qui
vient avec tout un kit pour la la
gestion en fait puis pour le bien-être
de votre barbe en 6 étapes du shampoing
jusqu'à la brosse au peigne l'huile le
revitalisant les petits ciseaux tout est
là dedans vous êtes vraiment allset la
barbe parfaite il me semble que ça
serait un beau cadeau de fête des pères
un bon petit kit menscape comme moi des
fois les peurs ça se laisse aller un peu
ça se néglige c'est un bon petit kit
avec quelque chose pour sentir bon
quelque chose pour gérer la pilosité de
de tout le corps en fait finalement ça
peut vraiment faire du bien moi je pense
que c'est genre des cadeaux que toutes
les peurs sont contents de recevoir donc
pour vous pour votre père on achète un
mascape on a un code promo c'est sans
filtre ça vous donne 20 % de rabais et
le shipping gratuit donc comment refuser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut humaine
téléphone
[Musique]
on parle genre nos villes comment ça va
maintenant j'aime ça j'ai connu les deux
tu sais je comprends pas comment
pourquoi ça intéresse des gens
merci de croire à mes projets
dis-moi ça m'intéresse parce que je vous
connais mais comment ça intéresse
jusqu'à
pour elle que ça intéresse que nos
opinions mettons l'intéresse d'autres
gens comme ça
comme d'autres
elle a été au Portugal peut-être pas
écouter ça même que l'Internet traverse
l'océan
comment ça va salut Po qui est 90
c'est la question de PO comment ça va ça
va ça va
vraiment
fatigué
de
ma période de la fin de l'hiver comme je
trouve c'est long je trouve c'est long
hier
la tempête de neige puis genre c'est un
peu tanal faut que j'avoue que c'est un
petit peu tanné
j'écoutais que ils veulent l'enlever
il y a plein de place au monde vraiment
pas de changement puis le raisonnement
derrière ça c'est que le soleil le matin
il serait plus bénéfique bénéfice
bénéfique plus bénéfique pour toi que le
soleil
mais moi j'ai entendu une spécialiste du
sommeil à la radio puis elle est pour
garder ça même pour garder l'heure qui
chante
c'est quoi son ben justement parce que
pas du monde se lève vers l'heure vers
ces heures-là ou soleil se lève versus
son ferait pas changement d'heure
si tu sens ce que je dis ça ça
coinciterait moins avec le lever la
plupart du monde ça serait le soleil se
relever que le monde soit pas levé et
puis ça servira comme rien c'est ce sont
son argument parce que le soleil se lève
plus tard
ouais c'est ça en fait non mais il
serait pas levé encore moins élevé
non non
un extrait qui est devenu viral sur les
médias sociaux si jamais vraiment arrivé
dans l'histoire du salon
à ce niveau-là c'était moi qui parlait
de mon truc de café
c'est là que tu réalises l'importance de
la portée des réseaux sociaux et à quel
point tu sais juste pour revenir un peu
en arrière quand que on a lancé avec les
filles sexoral c'est le podcast a
vraiment poignée une autre dimension
quand on a mis une en phase particulière
sur les réseaux sociaux pour créer des
extraits genre à une fréquence élevée là
puis sur Tik Tok principalement grâce à
Tommy le frère de Joanie qu'on salue
d'ailleurs possiblement pas en ce moment
mais
avec qui on travaille qui fait des
extraits vraiment rapides super efficace
super intéressant puis on a vu vraiment
qu'antomi d'embarquer dans dans le
dossier pour faire un extrait par jour
le podcast comme explosé même s'il y a
les probablement connaître un expansion
rapide ça le juste comme tout fait
sauter puis
on voit pourquoi parce que quand on a
fait quand cet extrait là où est-ce que
je parle le caféine de mon truc de café
est devenu viral
il y a plein de monde qui me disaient
qui du monde que genre que j'ai dans ma
vie avant à qui je parle plus vraiment
qui font comment j'ai écouté votre
Tic-Toc sur votre Tic-Toc sur la carte
sur la caféine puis là je faisais comme
mon Tik Tok à caféine genre c'est un
podcast complet tu sais plus j'ai
réalisé que plein de monde qui me
connaît moi évidemment c'est pas tout le
monde qui me connaît qui écoute le
podcast puis c'est bien correct comme ça
sauf que pleinement qui me connaît moins
qui sont comme beaucoup
que le podcast existe c'est parce que si
tu es si si c'est pas dans ta chambre
déco tu le vois juste pas passer mais où
des gens pour qui la tire
ce qui ont vu c'est pas à l'extrait d'un
podcast c'est une chose en soi exacte
dans l'ordre parce que une fois je
commence à fonctionner la viralité c'est
genre quand ça quand l'algorithme voit
que c'est un affaire qui est potentiel
de poignet il arrive dans le fait des
gens qui ont des intérêts communs c'est
assez standard en terme de connaissances
de l'algorithme fait du monde qui font
juste crawler puis là c'est cela cette
fois là j'apparais dans leur phase pour
parler de la caféine puis un jour ils
font l'association de comme que c'est du
contenu à planter c'est pas genre une
partie de contenu plus large c'est juste
comme ça c'est notre contenu voici notre
contenu on fait des Tic-Toc après ça oui
parce qu'après ça ce que j'ai réalisé
mettons le la caméra ici sur moi OK puis
là je te parle à toi plus je pourrais te
parler à toi de n'importe quoi avec
vraiment comme confiance en moi
maintenant je pourrais te dire là là tu
veux rentrer sur le marché de
l'immobilier là faut que tu achètes un
badge une maison en location mais ce que
tu fais là c'est que tu habites dans
l'appartement puis tu loues la maison
fait que là ça te permet
de la confiance tu pourrais ne pas être
là puis il y a plein de monde qui font
des podcasts vraiment ils regardent
devant les autres avec une qui font des
petits trucs demain avec une caméra qui
pointe ce réseau ils font comme si
quelqu'un en parlant quelqu'un ça donne
l'impression que l'autre personne écoute
en faisant genre oui oui tu as raison
d'être intelligent et tu fais juste dire
n'importe quoi avec confiance en faisant
comme si tu parlais à quelqu'un la
caméra de poing de côté tu as un micro
de même un setup de podcast puis le
monde va comme ce que là il fait des
pâtes
mais mon ex pense Tik Tok c'était ça toi
emmener on le voit toi réagir du genre
tu réponds genre que tu me manques plus
mais finalement c'est juste comme un
écran sur moi je pourrais être n'importe
qui dire n'importe quoi faire comme si
j'étais dans un setup de podcast puis le
monde serait pas que j'ai pas de podcast
c'est vraiment c'est génial il y a plein
de monde qui fonctionne
je suis vraiment les dinosaures
là-dessus j'ai même pas tic-tac sur mon
téléphone genre j'appellerai ce Tic-Toc
des fois parce que on fait des extraits
des podcasts mais genre j'en ai même pas
connaissance c'est genre c'est des
mesures à quel point si on parlait avec
Philippe Beaudoin l'intelligence
artificielle à quel point tu sais que
Tik Tok c'est du crack mais c'est du
crack parce que là j'ai commencé à
l'utiliser pour Epica puis pour en ma
page personnelle je pense comme une
vidéo par semaine de genre training de
course à pied
puis ça bloque le genre c'est genre des
30 mais l'écoute all of the way j'ai 600
personnes qui me suivent sur Tik Tok
sauf que quand j'arrive dans mon film
l'algorithme apprend à un rythme
démesuré mais donc tu écoutes une vidéo
jusqu'à fin ce qui traite de genre
dernièrement l'exemple que ça m'a donné
c'est le film suit le avec
avec Tom Hanks c'est comme le pilote
d'avion qui a atterrit dans la rivière
Hudson je regarde un extrait de ça parce
que les moteurs font sauter par des
oiseaux là
curiosité le soir dans ton fil le 3 3
affaires plus tard tu as un autre
extrait du film là je leur écoute parce
que je suis quand c'est passé plus tu
l'écoutes au complet puis là à place va
être trois extraits plus tard c'est deux
deux TikTok plus tard c'est la même
chose plus après ça c'est juste ça
maintenant c'est fou mais Instagram fait
de plus en plus seul tu es Instagram et
certaines époque tu avais juste les
trucs genre du monde que tu suivais dans
ton fils
je vois genre un mime un peu cute le
genre de couple le jambon parce que
c'est drôle
je n'ai que ce que plusieurs voix puis
plus genre je les écoute parce que je
trouve ça drôle plus j'ai ça c'est fou
d'Instagram au moins il prend un certain
temps ce conditionné ce que je réalisais
Tik Tok c'est que ça ça prend aucun
temps en une séance de scrolling de 15
minutes mettons là tu auras un
algorithme complètement con différents
que un que la séance d'après mettons
quand tu vas aller prendre tu vas aller
chier une autre fois là c'est fou c'est
après
puis genre des fois ces affaires
vraiment pas
comme
j’écoute la vidéo parce que c'est une
fille qui est là puis il y a une danse
afin de la danse genre elle a fait genre
en bikini afin de la danse puis genre
alors
au final ça m'intéresse pas comme
contenu mais tu as écouté la danse au
complet même fait que le top 7 danse là
tout le monde fait cette danse là tout
le monde puis c'est cousines font cette
danse là même ça le pot de sens genre
infini que j'ai écouté une fois ce trend
là puis là mais c'est juste le train de
défi cliniques qui font une danse
qui font genre nos sites Charlotte parce
que
pour le monde qui sont tout le temps sur
TiK ToK on va constate
juste comme tu vois facilement quelqu'un
qui est un petit peu aidé passé
deux heures sur TikTok sans même se
rendre compte que tu es pas allé plus
une fois je vois facilement sur arriver
là c'est fou même imagine si on avait ça
à l'école même tu sais là je parle comme
le vieux qui crie au comme comme nuage
mais genre on avait pas de téléphone
imagine Tik Tok maintenant
c'est fou ça mène la gestion des écrans
avec les enfants même c'est ça ça m'a
tout l'air d'être un casse-tête même mon
gars
mon neveu de 3 ans genre il accro là à
YouTube
c'est comme c'est la crise et puis
l'humidité qui est quand même rationné
quand même checker genre c'est OK genre
même si tu donnes puis tu dis là c'est
10 minutes après 10 minutes même si sûr
que ça va être chiant et enlever ouais
genre imagine juste dans comme le parent
est un petit peu fatigué là déjà
s'occuper de l'enfant là
fini c'est le blog là dessus tu as même
plus besoin d'en occuper
ça devient même une béquille pour les
parents ça devient un problème pour les
enfants puis même si
est proche en tabarnak de l'algorithme
genre moi là des fois là je tombe genre
dans une affaire où est-ce que je
regarde des vidéos genre de motivation
là comme de de fitness ou à lever puis
là tu vois rapidement
il y a comme un espèce de genre qui dit
un affaire crissement anti-féministe là
tu fais comme wow tu as un clic de
ça c'est ton modèle ce qui se trouve
maintenant un sérieux problème je
parlais je parlais de ça justement avec
quelqu'un que je nommerais pas que qui a
un enfant qui est proche de moi dans ma
vie puis son gars est tombé là-dedans
puis là était en ce moment en mode de
essayer de s'informer sur
comment aider quelqu'un qui est en train
de tomber dans raticulation parce que
vraiment c'est sûr que c'est passé
peut-être comme la technique de genre
faut jamais que tu confronte il faut que
tu questionnes c'est tout ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a vu dans notre podcast qu'on a
fait avec la sur la radicalisation et
maintenant la violence et vraiment
là-dedans c'est
c'est genre c'est comment le décrivait
mettons comment son gars il vit ça c'est
un gars de 15-16 ans c'est vraiment
comme secteur là son truc là puis un peu
comme les conspirationsnistes autant de
la covid
chaque fois qu'ils ont pas raison c'est
un argument qui utilise pour
dire qu'on raison tu sais comme quand
s'est fait emprisonner mettons-le pour
comme potentiellement distribution de
pornographie je venais le je pense
une vidéo est-ce qu'il disait qu'elle
allait se faire arrêter fait qu'il y
avait raison c'est le système qui est
conclut et puis c'est quand même ok
genre en fait cette vidéo là tu penses
pas que peut-être qu'il se battait un
peu le cul en faisant cette vidéo là
genre sachant que ce qui s'en vient
maintenant on l'avait dit il y a rien à
se reprocher puis convaincu convaincu
qu'il connaitre
mardi prochain
non non il joue avec des adultes
qui arrivent ils arrivent vicieusement
par le téléphone dans ta maison sans
même que tu t'en rendes compte ton
enfant il va des rallyes Trump et puis
qui qui
est dans le sol tu te doutes un peu
quelque chose qui va pas mal mais lui il
arrive pernicieusement même puis
apparemment que à l'école dans ce groupe
là son groupe d'amis c'est c'est
l'idolation d'Angry puis c'est à Québec
là c'est pas c'est pas state c'est fou
même de ces gens c'est inquiétant
j'aurais comme pensé qu'avec tous les
dernières années toutes les mouvements
sociaux que eux puis toutes les la
sensibilisation qui a eu toute
l'apprentissage que le monde en fait que
comme ce discours là fonctionnerait plus
genre j'ai l'impression que au contraire
c'est comme quelqu'un qui
j'ai pas que ça étouffé par genre
mettons les mouvements mis tout le
féminisme mais genre que comme le
quelqu'un qui va à l'extrême opposé ça
il fait du bien puis là c'est comme
justement ça ça
ça doublement une corde fébrine corde
que je sais pas qui sentait délaissé
puis laisser comme lui c'est comme le
plus grand sauveur ouais c'est ça puis
j'ai l'impression aussi maintenant que
tu en parles tu sais les mouvements
sociaux il y a pas un mouvement social
qui a valorisé les les jeunes
adolescents blancs mâles il y en a pas
un là
je veux dire avec raison
mais fait que toute le discours qui
entendent des dernières années c'est
comme ça les concerne jamais fait que là
il y a quelqu'un qui arrive qui leur
parle à vous êtes important genre moi je
trouve que vous êtes important fait que
là tu te fais valoriser par la personne
par une personne puis tu t'es pas fait
de valoriser et puis quasiment quasiment
à l'inverse c'est quasiment fait
dévaloriser les dernières années
puis là tu te fais dire par quelqu'un
que qui est important puis que tu vaux
la peine d'être consacrer à toi mais
c'est sûr que ça va ça va attirer des
gens c'est fou là
pour protéger ça mais même si
je sais même pas s'il y a une solution
c'est
aller justement en commission devant les
sénateurs aux États-Unis pour se faire
questionner genre puis un peu comme
quand Zuckerberg était allé genre il y a
personne là-dedans qui parle le même
langage que lui là c'est ça
est-ce que se connecte sur votre wifi à
la maison le lui fait genre qu'est-ce
que vous voulez dire je vous demande une
question simple vous voulez pas répondre
je comprends pas votre question est-ce
que Tik Tok se connecte avec wifi je
l'ai dit si vous connectez votre
téléphone au wifi et fait donc vous
pouvez aller dans d'autres d'autres
applications dans notre maison on les
fait genre
[Rires]
mais lui ses enfants sont à Singapour
puis ces enfants à Singapour il y a un
bam sur Tik Tok il fait que ses enfants
à lui utilisent pas Tic-Toc puis
l'argumentaire c'est genre est-ce que
vous laisseriez vos jeunes utiliser
votre propre application puis lui ça
répond il se dédouane un peu de la
réponse en disant
mes enfants habitent à Singapour fait
qui ont pas accès à Tic-Toc
13 ans utiliser TikTok à ces questions
là parce que ils ont pas le droit de
l'utiliser mais ça rend quand même long
là c'est fou là comme si il y avait pas
Facebook et un ban puis
vraiment tout Facebook
comme si on était à Montréal
ça vaut aucune différence en fait je
pense je suis sûr finalement
il y a plein de monde sur Facebook
on va prendre des questions c'est notre
éditorial sur les réseaux sociaux
quand même mais c'est top même quand tu
vois les gens
pour finir là dessus tu vois les trains
des fois tu fais comme
pour jouer la game faut que tu sois
comme en ligne pour poignet puis après
ça si tu joues pas la game tes efforts
comme pas la chandelle parce que comme
un peu à face dans quelque chose que ça
marche pas fait que soit tu joues à game
à fond en faisant les trains puis les
danses puis tu le fais comme Paul non
mais si tu le fais aussi des fois je
regarde des affaires puis comme je
regarde le nombre d'engagements sur ce
truc là puis je suis comme je peux pas
croire que ce contenu est autant
d'engagement je me dis dans le fond ça
la personne à qui ça s'adresse c'est
vraiment pas moi
ça me fait ça me fait rire parce que
hier j'étais avec ma blonde
sur Tik Tok avant de se coucher chose
que j'encourage personne à faire puis on
est tombé puis là je vois évidemment
encore une fois pas nommé non parce que
ça a rien de lancer du biff ça sert à
rien
mais un podcast comme connu au Québec
qui est sur Tik Tok un extrait puis
c'est juste comme
il y a rien qui se passe là on écoute
pendant une heure et demie une minute 30
de rien qui se passe
pourquoi pourquoi et comme Sylvie elle
comprendrait pas
des questions question du public
la première question qu'on a reçu le
Jeanne Beaubien top 3 des trucs pour
rester motivés à bouger top 3 mais moi
je peux donner
mes trucs ou des trucs
en fait moi je trouve que la question il
y a le mot motivé puis je pense pas que
la motivation c'est le moteur a bougé je
trouve que le mot motivation motivé
c'est quand tu es motivé à faire quelque
chose
c'est le goût de le faire rapide de le
faire puis c'est comme hier je suis
motivé
moi je trouve que c'est pas vraiment
comme ça que ça marche des fois ça le
lit des fois d'y aller des fois ça te
tente mais des fois ça tente crise ment
pas puis c'est le tu te dépends de la
motivation pour y aller souvent ça sera
pas assez
moi je pense que la motivation en fait
mettons le fameux 2 janvier que tout le
monde s'inscrit au Jam parce que là
je me prends en main je suis motivé je
m'entraîner puis que ça dure deux
semaines ça dure 0 jours puis que ça
arrive juste pas
pour moi la meilleure façon de bouger
puis de rester actif puis c'est pas la
motivation c'est la planification
ces mettons de ok je veux faire telle
affaire de nouveau dans ma vie que je
faisais pas
ben je vois le planifier pour que ça
fonctionne dans ma vie parce que tu dis
c'était de rentrer une nouvelle chose on
vit toutes 24 heures par jour ça 24
heures là ce temps-là est divisé en
certaines choses liste essaie de rentrer
un nouveau un nouvel élément là-dedans
il faut qu'il y ait la place pour ça il
faut que tu fasses la place pour ça
n'évitablement il faut que tu tasses de
quoi
c'est assez là
si tu
avec tes amis si tu travailles ou c'est
probablement du temps que tu passes sur
ton sel à checker des Tik Tok justement
ou checker Netflix parce que je veux
dire on passe tout le monde met du temps
dans des trucs qui sont pas essentiels à
la vie mettons que tu pourrais mettre
facture
tu peux sans doute faire du temps mais
il faut quand même que tu planifies dans
ton horreur parce que de penser que
juste le fait de t'inscrire au gym
va faire que comme par magie tu vas y
aller puis ça va devenir notre routine
ça arrivera pas comme tu dises ok ben
maintenant pour que ça ça fonctionne il
faut que ma routine soit souple et je
vais y aller je vois me lever un peu
plus tôt puis je vais y aller on allait
travailler où je veux en revenant du
travail aller avant le souper whatever
mais faut tout plaquer pour que ça
marche parce que si c'est pas ça il y a
toujours de quoi qu'il va faire en sorte
que tu auras pas le temps ou que ça
marchera pas ta journée là parce que ta
journée était déjà remplie de 24 heures
tu es déjà rempli de choses
la motivation
je pense que tu es le fait de c'est bien
plus de justement le planifier qui
demain matin 8h je vais au gym ou je
vais courir
le mettre dans ton horaire puis que le
rendu le lendemain matin à 8h que ça
tente que ça tente pas
c'est la chose qui va faire que la
planification puis le commitment qui va
faire que tu vas que tu vas le faire pas
la motivation c'est vraiment une bonne
façon de voir ça une excellente réponse
à cette question mettons moi je faisais
le maintenant je m'entraîne par moi-même
mais si quand j'allais au jump décrocher
il faut que tu t'inscrives une session
une fois que tu t'inscrit une session
mettons il y a 12 places dans le cours
je vois pas j'ai un frère de
Saint-Pierre parce que je peux aller
puis en plus c'est comme chien j'ai pris
la place de quelqu'un qui aurait voulu y
aller puis il y a pas une fois où je me
suis inscrit que je parlais ouais parce
que là je me dis je me suis commise
quelque chose il y a une conséquence je
veux pas puis je fais chier du monde si
je vois pas
semer ce le comité de s'inscrire mais si
tu peux juste le faire toi envers
toi-même de le mettre dans ton agenda
il y a pas une fois que quelqu'un est
allé dans s'entraîner dans la vie puis
que regretter après non ça c'est clair
mais genre c'est tout le temps positif
tout le temps fier de toi après puis
la motivation finit par arriver à torse
de faire à force de le faire d'être
forcé de le faire puis de faire le
comitément ammani la motivation apparaît
parce que là tu vois de l'amélioration
tu vois genre
des changements dans comment tu te sens
dans comment tes objectifs dans
tu te rapproches de quelque chose puis
le tu as le goût de continuer parce que
c'est écrit mon travail ce que ça me
tentait pas de faire le travail que j'ai
mis les affaires que j'ai mis là ça paye
puis là c'est d'abord ça c'est vraiment
le fun
surtout pour
que la route en mouvement c'est dans ton
horaire dans ta routine
le Amani ça devient facile tu sais ça
devient normal parce que c'est c'est
juste sur ma vie je me lève je
m’entraîner je suis mal journée je me
sens bien c'est le fun ça ça prend des
mois avant que c'était avant d'arriver à
cet point-là mais toutes les débuts
souvent le monde abandonne-le parce que
parce que parce que ça attendre à ce
qu'il y a une motivation contre la
motivation mais
motivation là est trop effacée fiable
ouais c'est vraiment bon c'est vraiment
bon comme façon de voir ça puis
une des affaires que ça fait de réussir
de planifier dans ton horaire parce que
j'aime l'idée de vraiment comme moi
c'est comme ça je le fais je fonctionne
aussi mettons quand j'ai des tradings
importants
faut que tu réserves ta place sur la
piste dont la piste extérieure il faut
que tu faut que je bloque une case
horaire dans mon dans mon horaire pour
pas avoir de colle pour le studio auprès
d'avoir de trucs à faire pour les
business il faut que j'aille vraiment
une cage une plage horaire que je me
bloque maintenant pour pas prendre de
rendez-vous dans ce moment-là parce que
c'est là je vais m'entraîner puis ce que
ça fait ça c'est que
c'est la petite voix qui négocie là la
petite voix dans ta tête qui négocie
quand tu veux peut-être pas vraiment
aller t'entraîner puis que tu as
négocier avec toi là quand tu as des une
obligation d'être là une obligation en
guillemets pour ce que tu viens de dire
ton exemple de prospect est super bon là
petite voix qui négocie elle vient
jamais à l'appareil jamais elle vient
jamais dire ah tu es sûr ça tente elle
vient jamais dire ça parce que c'est ça
que tu fais comme rentrer à job il y a
pas de petites voix qui vient négocier
tu es sûr qu'aujourd'hui tu veux rentrer
à job c'est comme tu as pas le choix
j'ai pas le choix de rentrer à pied tu
rentres à job c'est vraiment une belle
façon de voir ça puis l'autre affaire
que j'ajouterais à ça
c'est que une fois que ça devient comme
une fois ça rentre dans ta routine que
ça devient juste ça
moi c'est quand les objectifs arrivent
tu te mets des objectifs puis une fois
que les objectifs arrivent là ça vient
faire un petit peu la même chose comme
quand un gros training à faire ça tente
pas il y a pas de petites voix qui vient
négocier parce que tu as pas le choix
sinon tu n'arrivera pas à ton objectif
fait que moi je rajouterais juste mes
objectifs à ta réponse puis c'est
vraiment c'est la façon de le faire je
pense tu es pas il y a pas de solution
miracle il y a pas de il y a personne
qui va tu l'as bien dit il y a personne
ça va tenter tout le temps mais moi ça
me tente quasiment moins souvent que ça
me tente pas plus souvent que ça me
tente d'aller m'entraîner mais surtout
quand c'est des gros training genre je
sais que ça va être ça va faire mal ça
me péter le tien faut vraiment que tu
ailles une autre raison que je la
motivation parce que la motivation elle
arrive quand tu es rendu au milieu du 7
puis que là Thomas mais que ça paye là
c'est le fun tu sais quand tu es dedans
puis c'est plus important je pense
de je pense même que c'est plus
important de respecter les comics même
que tu t'es fait
que
de vraiment mettons est-ce que c'était
nécessaire que sans rien cette
journée-là dans le sens que tu sais
mettons il y a des journées qui étaient
plus fatigués ou que peut-être que ça
serait correct c'est pas une journée de
congé mais le fait de se lever le matin
et puis avoir juste l'option de se dire
je mérite une journée de congé
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment fatigué
ben c'est comme le lendemain le
lendemain qui est à fait ça va tenter
deux fois moins parce que là
mettons mettons ce matin je me suis levé
puis justement je me sentais quand même
crissement
hacker la veille puis genre un peu raide
j'étais comme ah je me sens genre c'est
juste des petites tensions dans le dos
que je t'ai comme lui je pense que si je
vois je vais enlever de quoi de l'eau je
vais me faire mal
mais juste pour garder mettons j'aurais
pu juste rien faire juste pour garder
l'habitude de bouger en me levant j'ai
fait genre 30 minutes de yoga juste pour
dire que comme je fais de quoi ça c'est
ma routine puis peu importe c'est quoi
ça bougera pas ça bougera pas
[Musique]
souvent quand je parle c'est quand je
dis mettons c'était quoi notre régime
d'entraînement au secondaire
[Musique]
il y a trois matins la semaine qu'on ait
à 5h30 6h dans l'eau deux heures de
temps ça c'est à 5h et 10 sur le deck
puis toutes les après-midi de semaine un
autre deux heures des fois des muscu
après puis
montre font comme genre comment comment
tu faisais comment tu fais pour rester
motivé
c'est comme c'était pas une question de
discipline c'était juste une question de
c'est ça ma vie c'est comme comment tu
fais pour chaque matin de lever pour
aller au travail c'est comme si c'est ça
que tu fais pas plus compliqué une fois
que ça devient intégré c'est comme c'est
même pas si
difficile que
c'est que ça devient un peu
ça devient comme
juste plus t'en fais plus ça devient
normal puis tant que tu as pas fait tant
que tu as pas fait de quoi de
plus plus intense que ce que tu fais
dans ta vie de tous les jours tu peux
comme pas le concevoir mais quand ça
devient ta vie
c'est ça que tu fais genre l'histoire
même tu sais juste comme comme on
parlait tantôt en médecine genre
formation même si genre
invivable c'est comme tentant mettons tu
entends leurs horaires puis c'est juste
comme ça je peux pas même ça se peut
juste pas que ça existe genre c'est trop
le c'est ça pas de sens mais les autres
ça rendent pas quand même il faut le
résidence au complet ils font ça mais
genre tout le monde est là-dedans tout
le monde a le même bateau puis si c'est
comme c'est la vie qu'on choisit
[Musique]
pour pratiquer cinq heures par jour
c'est comme Norman c'est ça je faisais
je le faisais mais je restais à toutes
les soirs jusqu'à 9h puis je partais je
partais après même quand j'avais fait
mon 4 5 heures de guitare puis c'était
comme c'était juste ça ma vie là tu sais
ma routine aurait pu être aller prendre
une bière c'est ça à toutes les soirs
était resté au cégep jusqu'à 9h puis
pratiquer
ça mettons-le juste pour faire une
petite parenthèse sur la pratique de
musique on a reçu pilou peut-être
vous allez entendre ceci puis tiens s'il
y a une affaire qui est en commun
on pourra on pourra bondir sur une
question après la mission à faire que en
commun les gens qui gagnent leur vie
avec la musique là souvent c'est une
espèce de période de deux trois ans à
genre 5 heures par jour de pratique de
musique parce qu'après ça seul
tu l'as encore peut-être que tu peux
plus faire les affaires que tu faisais
mettons mécaniquement quand tu
pratiquais 5 heures par jour mettons le
peut-être tu peux me corriger si je me
trompe mais ça il y a des tonnes de jazz
vraiment
pour le reste de ta ville tant que tu
joues encore de la guide puis que tu
t'en vas pas en exil puis même
probablement en exilé l'histoire du gars
qui jouait de la du saxophone il a
arrêté de jouer directement
[Musique]
ça faire de la musique là on dirait que
c'est comme un passage obligé pour
arriver à un stade où ce qui était
capable de faire de gagner ta vie
peut-être compétent dans n'importe quoi
tu peux me faire
une période de
de travail de
fond moi c'est c'était ça
dans la vie c'est comme l'eau c'est le
moment où est-ce qu'il faut que comme je
mette les bouchées triples si je fais
pas ça c'est comme
ça
tu le fais après ça c'est un bagage qui
te reste tout le temps type ça c'est
le sport la musique mais tu n'as pas
quelque chose qui demande qui est un
travail de longue haleine si tu veux
écrire un livre si tu veux n'importe
quoi faut que tu faut que tu le mettes
dans ton horaire tu le respectes non
négociable
il disait que lui il y a trois heures
tous les jours des fois je vais être
assez dans mon ordi j'aurais rien écrit
mais je dois être assis devant mon ordi
puis il fallait qu'il fasse pitié
avec sa femme née qui disait genre je
peux pas m'occuper des enfants pendant
trois heures là genre tu es chez nous
c'est pas ça je peux pas c'est ma
période à moi fait que fait quoi
ben écoute Fanny plouf qui demande sida
mangé à faire en podcast sur la musique
on a déjà parlé là
le fait de le dire en plus deux fois
plus
question pleine méthode sur le Podcast
comment est-ce qu'on gère les longues
entretiens sans note
je pense que
je pense que on gère en
étant prêt un peu
à tout éventualité d'en connaître assez
sur la personne sur le sujet pour pas
être complètement à court de sujet de
questions de choses à dire puis de
d'être capable de d'alimenter quelque
chose factique si parce que c'est les
discussions moi tout le temps sur des
terrains inconnus inconnus non prévus
d'avoir assez large un peu des
connaissances sur le sujet puis
connaissance générale mettons pour être
capable de comme
patauger là-dedans c'est parce que si on
était complètement cloués sur toute je
vous ai donné les discussions ça sera en
surface en mode
je pense c'est ça mais tu sais c'est
le travail d'une vie juste d'être
curieux puis des comme de
genre s'intéresser à plein d'affaires
puis de d'être capable de
courir
sinon c'est
moi quand j'arrive maintenant dans un
des affaires qu'on fait au sans fil
c'est qu'on se parle jamais avant
l'autre on sait jamais parler une fois
je pense avant de faire un podcast de on
je parle avant le métier on se parle pas
de qu'est-ce qu'on va de quoi on va
parler tu vois puis moi je me garde je
vais tout le temps comme trois
questions/s sujet dans ma tête avant un
podcast je mets je me dis mais attends
pour en préparant dans ma préparation le
fait de cibler trois sujets puis toi tu
dois faire sensiblement la même chose
des fois on a les mêmes des fois non
mais
des fois j'en utilise une
puis le podcast dure deux heures des
fois j'ai utilisé les trois puis j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut qu'on rame pour
amener le podcast au dessus d'une heure
et quart tout dépendant des invités puis
de comment sont à l'aise de
parler de leur truc mais
c'est ça c'est juste d'être capable de
d'avoir ça dans le fondateur fait que
c'est comme je suis jamais stressé
je suis jamais en train de pas écouter
la personne en train de me dire bon de
quoi tu parles de quoi tu vas parler
après de quoi tu vas parler après de
quoi tu veux parler après fait tu peux
rester dans le moment avec la personne
puis en restant le moment avec la
personne en sachant que comme des un bac
à plein si jamais la France finit quand
tu penses que c'est une virgule mais
finalement c'est un pointe ça arrive des
fois ça c'est tout le temps
déstabilisant quand on a invité va tu
vas avoir l'impression qu'il veut
continuer encore pendant une phrase
complète mais que finalement ça finit
quand tu finis de même mais ça sent que
tu as tout le temps un backup plan là tu
peux rester en conversation puis souvent
ce que ça ça fait c'est que tu as
d'autres questions qui pop en écoutant
la personne sur la personne ça fait une
conversation qui est vraiment plus
organique que de juste comme question
réponses questions complémente réponse
c'est que ça permet d'être plus de
garder le flow plus plus efficace puis
des fois c'est ce mot des fois quand je
dis
je l'ai déjà dit au podcast c'est ça
c'est vraiment intéressant là j'étais en
train d'aller dans ma dans mon affaire à
l'arrière puis d'essayer de replier une
des questions que j'avais planifié avant
que là j'ai juste pas genre top of my
head parce que j'étais en train de
mettre dans une conversation
en fait parce que justement ça fait de
quoi de plus organique puis de plus
ça ressemble plus à une conversation
normale que tu aurais avec quelqu'un que
mettons justement avoir des questions
préparées avec un plan puis avec un
peut-être que c'est d'avoir ton plan de
question ça peut ça peut peut-être faire
un podcast
plus structuré avec un début au milieu
d'une fin ce qui est pas de mauvaise
chose mais aussi ça peut brimer la
créativité puis ça peut brimer le
naturel d'une conversation effectivement
de faire de quoi que peut-être que des
fois mettons à respectifs
plus un genre de parcours de même dans
le podcast finalement ça a juste comme
pardonner parce qu'on a commencé à
chanter quelque chose puis qu'on est
parti quelque chose mais
ça laisse le place à la surprise ouais
exactement
puis là
quand même ouais c'est ça exactement
ce qu'on fait en ce moment puis des fois
je me prenais à dire non parce qu'on
était plus en mode
pour faire des podcasts faut faire des
podcasts peut-être qu'on peut rebondir
sur une question là je pense qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui nous avait demandé
si on est-ce que vous comptez faire non
que c'est pas ça
peut même falloir trouver
des personnalités publiques musiciens
humoristes etc ça ça a vraiment eu un
gros switch pour moi quand on a fait
genre on va se détacher complètement de
ça pas parce qu'on ne le fera plus
jamais loin de là on a reçu pilou je la
mangue est un musicien mais quand on a
commencé à juste faire un long on avait
juste du monde que ça tente de parler
puis des sujets que ça nous tente
d'aborder puis en faisant ça fait que
ma curiosité comme
rejaillit on dirait puis que là quand
j'arrivais sur des podcasts j'avais
comme c'est genre
j'avais des questions
légitimes curieuses à lui poser tu sais
puis j'avais hâte c'est quand qu'on
savait que je l'avais bouquet j'étais
quand j'étais vraiment content j'étais
comme un pied non là on va je vais poser
des questions même chose pour sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est comme
un sujet qui est tellement vaste et
important puis ça fait que les questions
que tu amènes avec une curiosité honnête
et légitime ça rend ça intéressant c'est
que ça fait que le contenu
peut-être s'élève au-dessus d'une simple
conversation juste pour avoir une
conversation tu sais puis ça je trouve
que c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
qui me nourrit plus que qui me nourrit
autant que ça me nourritait au début tu
sans fil ça me nourrit plus maintenant
il y a comme un passage où est-ce que me
nourrissait moins peut-être puis là
comme là j'ai l'impression que ça me
nourrir autant que au début tu sais
d'aller dans cette plus cet aspect là
plus comme des trucs qui m'intéressent
fondamentalement pour vrai dire
on en parle souvent cette période-là
je pense que faisait des bons podcasts
intéressants c'était juste des invités
intéressants aussi intéressant je pense
que vous auront été peut-être juste on
le faisait plus automatique
nous nous puis comme de fait
l'intérêt pour le sans filtre
réaugmente maintenant le tir on le voit
dans nos chiffres mettons là on a comme
des des chiffres qu'on
de voir que mettons pour un podcast
comme justement avec Philippe Beaudoin
personne qui est plus là c'est pas
conclu mais genre il y a personne qui
plus personne dans le sens c'est pas une
personne dépublique c'est pas quelqu'un
qui a un attrait son nom pas de mais
c'est quelqu'un qui est calé dans son
enfer qui connaissait qui vient nous
parler d'un sujet intéressant
il y avait la question
tu me diras si on a déjà parlé de ça on
a déjà répondu parce que moi j'ai une
mémoire de poisson rouge il y a spa qui
demande crise de la trentaine point
d'interrogation le temps qui passe les
questions extensibles
de période de 6-7 ans de genre comme je
stresse juste de la vie adulte là parce
que
je veux partir ailleurs pour garder
suspense de mon histoire
deux mois je suis comme je me tu me suis
graffigné la main en attachant mes
cheveux j'avais les cheveux longs deux
mois puis je regarde mes ongles là je
fais
mes ongles sont longs
je pense même pas genre je vais me les
gruger genre puis là je fais juste
continuer pour amener ça me réarie de
Jean m'accrocher en face
la première fois que j'achète un coupon
toute ma vie puis là je me coupe les
hommes puis là je me suis coupé les
ongles avec un coupon qui pour la
première fois de toute ma vie je suis
allé m'acheter un coupon je me couper
les ongles est-ce que tu ranger les
ongles des pieds aussi je les arraché
avec mes doigts
j'ai pu de dettes de cartes de crédit
mais
d'études sont remboursées
puis j'ai pas j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
à mon compte en banque mais toute les
dettes sont remboursées je suis dans le
verre pour la première fois depuis que
je suis rentré à l'université en 2011
puis en
simultanément à ça j'arrête de me ronger
les ongles
puis je sais pas si le lien est direct
comme ça mais c'est arrivé dans le même
deux semaines
bref pour répondre à la question
c'est la première fois maintenant
que j'envisage genre comme être
financièrement
libre de pouvoir faire ce que je veux
puis ça comme aussi tassé l'anxiété de
la trentaine on dirait avec parce que
j'avais l'impression d'être un étudiant
encore tu as l'impression de devoir me
débattre mais depuis beaucoup de choses
à faire là sur mon propre chef genre à
place de Stacker puis d'essayer de
rembourser mes dettes j'ai dit on va
investir dans un studio je lance une
autre compagnie effectivement je
réinvestissais mon argent un peu partout
aussi sauf qu'à chaque fois c'était
comme un peu la carte de crédit la marge
de crédit qui absorbait tout ça
mais là mais on dirait que je suis comme
une nouvelle fenêtre de possibilités qui
viennent s'ouvrir puis ça le comment
enlever mon anxiété
que je réalise que j'ai pu genre une
dette qui est comme juste omniprésente
comme qui existe juste un comme quelque
chose qui devient un stress latent
presque imperceptible mais qui est tout
le temps là
peut-être que j'ai l'impression que j'ai
eu comme plus des réflexions
prétentaine on dirait que de sentir la
trentaine qui est arrivé
je pensais beaucoup et puis que je pense
que ça le
on dirait que je suis comme un marqueur
temporel important
que j'ai des reminders du temps qui
passe ça me ça me fait me questionner
sur genre justement est-ce que est-ce
que les décisions que je prends sont les
bonnes est-ce que je suis à la place que
que je voudrais être est-ce que je suis
sur la bonne direction de ma vie que
j'ai toujours que j'ai voulu prendre
puis je pense dans ma vingtaine j'ai
fait beaucoup de trucs
[Musique]
me disant que c'était genre temporaire
ou critique sans vraiment trop me poser
de questions juste comme juste le faire
un peu de manière ça va demander si tu
vraiment ça que je vais faire ultimement
ou sachant que c'est pas ça que je vais
faire ultimement mais me disant ben le
sait ce où je dois passer obligé ou à
l'heure puis
c'est là en fait je me j'ai jamais été
aussi
jamais senti aussi
à la bonne place surtout les aspects
j'ai tout le temps tu mettes dans ma
carrière musicale voulu faire des
projets c'est de créatif le phone c'est
puis le mettons ce que je fais je t'ai
voulu plus faire des albums faire la
réalisation le si jamais autant fait de
ça
avec une blonde que je me vois tu sais
vraiment
projeté dans le futur construire des
trucs on dirait que c'est comme tous les
aspects de ma vie sont comme à bonne
place on dirait la trentaine puisse
toutes vos comme bien fait on dirait
elle a trentaine ça va quand même être
cool la vingtaine que que j'ai plus aéré
un peu que je me suis posé des questions
ou tu sais que j'ai cherché ou que
que j'étais pas exactement là où je
voulais être ben c'est comme si en fait
toutes les graines que j'ai un peu semé
à gauche à droite sans trop savoir là je
récolte le fruit de ce travail-là de
cette recherche là puis
on dirait je suis vraiment optimiste sur
comme où ça s'en va on dirait que genre
la trentaine ça va être great en fait
c'est la trentaine d'accord
en fait j'étais plus inquiet avant
on dirait que je sais pas
17 18 19 20 l'intrigue chaque fête
chaque anniversaire j'étais comme genre
le temps passe trop vite puis là c'est
comme si j'aurais voulu être un grand
produit je le dis que comme 20 ans
je suis pas
je suis pas célèbre ou je sais pas
Mozart faites-le faites-le c'est comme
le désillusion totale mais genre une
fois que tu passes ça puis que tu
acceptes que tu es pas Mozart mais que
c'est cool pareil
c'est juste c'est juste greati c'est
juste le fun c'est je pense que
justement le type fin autour de la
vingtaine et comme tellement idéaliste
puis tu penses que tout est
tout est à ta portée puis le finalement
tu te rend compte que bah non ça fait
comme mal mais une fois que tu passes ça
puis là tu te rends compte ok non mais
ce que j'ai ou ce que je peux avoir
c'est quand même
si je fais reprendre juste les bonnes
décisions et puis fait qu'on dirait que
c'est ça la trentaine d'arriver ça a
juste fait comme j'ai juste réaligné une
coupe d'affaires changer une coupe
d'affaires certaines affaires quand même
important
mais genre qui était difficile mais qui
au final comme crème aujourd'hui
j'ai crushment bien fait de prendre ses
décisions là parce que le aujourd'hui je
suis vraiment bonne place
sauf que
c'est des années c'était pas sûr de
quelque chose dans ta vie tu sais puis
que là après des années tu es toujours
pas sûr ça encore à m'amener c'est comme
peut-être que c'est pas la bonne affaire
de prendre des décisions
c'est top mais après ça il faut que tu
trouves vraiment qui est belle louche ta
bonne place et ça c'est la bonne affaire
c'est vraiment
c'est vrai c'est bon
il disait que je l'entendais parler sur
genre la vingtaine puis le comme
situation tout le temps sur genre est-ce
que ça va bien aller genre est-ce que
tout doit être correct toujours
qu'est-ce que je dois faire plus tard
qu'est-ce que plus il disait écoute ça
sert à rien de
de poser cette question là maintenant
c'est parce que premièrement ça va
sûrement bien aller puis du deuxièmement
mettons que ça va pas bien ça ira pas
bien dans ta trentaine quoi ça te sert
de
passer à ce maintenant
c'est comme ça va aller
effectivement comme tu dis non seulement
les graines qui te semis et récoltent
maintenant mais aussi c'est des graines
que tu as semées que tu réalises que
finalement c'était pas splantes là tu
voulais c'est effectivement
je vois la trentaine justement comme
genre tout le travail de connaissances
de soi de travail de vrais travail de
comme apprendre des choses je veux dire
devenir meilleur à des skills tout ça
fait que tu arrives dans ta trentaine
avec un bagage qui fait que là tu peux
comme
j'ai entendu Julien run mon ami Julien
Le Journal de l'entrepreneurs
puis sur son podcast le journal d'un
entrepreneur il parle de il pose une
question puis la question c'est tout le
monde qui écrit avec une des business
une des projets puis ça peut saler
vraiment plus large une idée de projets
mettons là
tu fais proposer un enfant tu sais puis
lui il dit pour savoir si l'idée tu veux
vraiment la faire
répondre à cette question là si demain
matin je te donne 500000 pièces dans ton
compte en banque tu le fais tu quand
même puis cette question là est vraiment
je trouve je trouve vraiment le concept
intéressant parce que
[Musique]
c'est drôle parce que c'était
je me suis posé récemment tu mettons
juste genre qu'est-ce que je ferais
maintenant si je gagne
roi je fais des albums avec tel artiste
je suis à faire là j'étais comme la
tournée je veux dire c'est juste oui
c'est genre
je vois mes amis puis de deux on a du
fun puis genre on fait de la musique
puis le mettons les albums en train de
faire avec les artistes et que je
travaille je suis comme tout le temps je
voulais faire créer de la musique genre
je le ferai pareil
pas les choses que je fais que si
j'avais 3 millions dans mon compte ou
vous avez préparé avec le cassé dans le
fond de place peut-être que tu ferais
c'est top comme pilule ouais c'est ça
je vais me faire un test
de plein de de
guide d'affaires mais si l'essence si tu
touches pas à l'essence c'est great là
des temps comme on est là
c'est une bonne question
je sais pas à quelle heure
il y a beaucoup de types de coureurs
mais tu es ma page personnelle pour
avoir des types de couleur
sur nos affaires
des athlètes à tous toutes les semaines
pratiquement pour des petits tocs de
geek de sport
ça c'est vraiment le but le plus
incroyable podcast parce qu'on cherche
des questions
[Musique]
comment conciliez-vous travail ami amour
avec tous vos nombreux projets
ça c'est une bonne question quand même
puis
je pense que
si maintenant j'ai des bons amis que ça
fait six mois que j'ai pas vu ça c'est
quand même quand tu réfléchis à ça mais
ton des bons amis que je reverrai demain
et puis que je serai comme parmi mes
meilleurs amis YouTube puis c'est juste
la vie va vite même puis tout le monde a
géré ça on travaille son couple nous on
a la chance de se voir dans le contexte
du studio parce que si on n'avait pas le
studio nos vies sont quand même
différentes là c'est pas sûr qu'on se
verrait tant que ça
mais c'est top même la conciliation de
tout ça c'est top je pense que ça
revient à ce qu'on parlait plutôt de
comme juste planifie ta vie comme tu
veux que comment tu veux qu'elle soit
puis après ça essaie de réaliser ça
c'est de penser c'est quoi les
proportions
qui
fonctionnent pour toi c'est en termes de
voir tes amis versus passer du temps
avec tableau
de travail versus faire toute
l'entraînement et puis l'entraînement je
veux dire comment il est mortel
une heure par jour
une heure par jour c'est le temps c'est
le temps de dragon un Game of Thrones
d'ailleurs j'ai commencé à jamais
écouter
la dernière fois que ça m'avait fait ça
c'était Game of Thrones où est-ce que je
sais pas je t'avais dit ça mais où
est-ce que tu es pendant l'épisode pas
afin pour le cliffhanger je vais écouter
l'autre mais pendant l'épisode genre au
milieu de l'épisode tu fais genre
tu as la réalisation que ce que tu
écoutes c'est de la bombe au pendant que
tu es en train de l'écouter genre c'est
vraiment fucking bon pour vrai pitié
mais là tu vas être obligé d'écouter
Game of Thrones
mon gars tu es tellement chanceux de
jamais
je les ai réécouter au complet même je
t'invite tellement puis en plus c'est
comme tellement pile mettons genre de
truc que j'aime
c'est sûr que je vois capoter c'est
incroyable puis je me dis à ça
ça va c'est pas trop là parce que c'est
comment
je vais aller j'ai tellement chanceuse
mais
ouais bref c'est ça
je veux dire l'entraînement
pour mettons les moments où est-ce que
je t'ai avec mes amis c'est quand qu'on
est ici au studio puis quand que je fais
de la musique avec des amis factés pour
moi le travail puis les amitiés c'est
comme un peu lié non parce que tu mettes
maintenant je sors pas je veux dire je
vois pas
vendredi soir
plus vraiment tu es avant c'est plus
ma petite routine mais
ça demande je pense ça demande la
planification ça demande comme juste
pitié mettons avec ma blonde on a comme
notre routine qui est un peu
deux semaines des fois je vais arriver
un peu plus tard mais si j'arrive jamais
à minuit
je sais que comme on a une petite tant
qu'on mange ensemble qu'on se couche
ensemble qu'on se lève ensemble déjà ça
même si on se voit pas tant que ça si
nous avons au moins ça au moins avant de
se coucher on peut
se parler un peu se coller un peu
écouter une staffaire ensemble se lever
ensemble passer un peu de temps le matin
ensemble si après ça on a des journées
de fou ben au moins essayer il y a ceux
qui est comme constante
[Musique]
moi pour ça je trouve que de trouver
quelqu'un tu as un niveau de
d'occupation qui semblable aussi parce
que sinon ou sinon il y a comme une
dynamique
de balancements qui s'installe le timoto
qui est quelqu'un qui travaille vraiment
moins que l'autre qui est ta maison
le soir que tu arrives à la maison le
l'autre arrive à 9h la Brou dans le
toupet fatigué mettons je pense que
c'est important de trouver quelqu'un qui
qui a vraiment un niveau de vie ou un
rythme de vie semblable au tien que les
mêmes attentes en termes de commentant
tu veux passer avec l'autre puis comment
tu veux le passer tu sais il y en a des
coupes que les deux sont super
indépendantes du monde que je dois tu
connais que ça fait genre 6 ans
d'ensemble il y a peut-être même pas
ensemble puis genre ils se voient genre
trois semaines puis genre ça fait
l'affaire des deux uniques sont full
fusionnel je pensais trouver quelqu'un
qui a un équilibre que les deux soient
comme content satisfait là-dedans puis
c'est les polka juste d'en parler puis
de trouver une manière que ça fonctionne
puis une bonne affaire aussi c'est de
c'était capable c'est soit de conjuguer
ami ou travail comme t'expliquer mais
aussi entraînement et coupe c'est
maintenant ma blonde des fois on va
faire des longues sorties le samedi puis
à place d'être une période où est-ce que
moi je suis tout seul pendant deux
heures puis elle est seule pendant deux
heures mais on fait une activité
ensemble facile ça reste du temps à
faire quelque chose mais c'est pour ça
qu'elle était quand même
[Musique]
des bons conseils en octobre
on avait la question est-ce que c'est
dans nos plans d'ouvrir un studio SF à
Québec
je pensais on est déjà passé
sérieusement on a déjà même
chercher des locaux actuellement
on ira repensé dernièrement
parce qu'au moment qu'on qu'on a voulu
le faire je pense que le
on se questionnait sur comme il y a
dessus assez de monde à Québec qui va le
faire des podcasts pour qu'un studio
podcast comme existe j'ai l'impression
que voulait une coupe Dany c'était pas
le cas peut-être que c'est plus le cas
parce que aussi une diversification
vraiment des podcasts
et puis juste si mettons recevoir
on a vu arriver un mur que la culture
que le domaine culturel du Québec à
éviter si on avait arrivé un mur en
disant une limite de podcast les gens
vont faire le thé quand que c'était
toutes les podcasts c'était le même
concept puis là il y a eu un gros Swatch
puis on le voit ici au studio le tien
des podcasts
pour beaucoup plus de podcasts qu'on
pensait initialement
immobilier des podcasts de toutes les
mortels mais que le manque s'intéresse à
tel domaine ils vont vouloir écouter de
construction ici marche
que je pense que c'est vraiment comme
l'avenir du podcast c'est beaucoup là du
moins la diversification
pour la première fois parler pendant
deux heures quand il avait juste vu dans
des contextes de télé maman qui cette
personne-là
je veux dire il y a une limite l'espèce
de nouveautés ou d'avoir accès à une
personne de manière c'est comme pu aussi
nouveau que c'était le 4h
mais je pense que maintenant au Québec
peut-être qu'il y aurait plus
pour ce genre de podcast le plus
diversifié une demande
c'est aussi d'avoir ici on a la chance
inouï d'avoir une colle puis
c'est dur de trouver une colle puis
surtout d'en trouver un quand c'est pas
une Java temps plein puis avec des
horaires variables selon la location du
truc
comme quelqu'un qui soit sur place mais
comme disponible pas vraiment temps
plein et puis c'est comme ça devient un
peu compliqué mais c'est pas dit qu'on
quand on y retournera pas une croix là
dessus
un invité que vous rêvez de recevoir
quelqu'un d'accessible quand même
moi c'est Jean leloupe
c'est Rebecca McDon qui fait l'entrevue
avec Jean Lelou genre
est vraiment genre
il dit des affaires qui ont comme pas de
sens le pied elle est là puis
genre elle essaie de le suivre dans son
délire mais lui genre rien seul tu la
profession les fait genre tout c'est
quoi ta job enfin même un job c'est je
suis en train de la faire là il fait
genre c'est pas une Jobs
tu travailles pas toi ça fait genre
trois jours que je dors pas parce que
c'est un festival que je fais des
entrevues à gauche à droite
il y a pas beaucoup de monde
vraiment pas il est vraiment très peu
d'entrevue que j'ai un look sont bonnes
parce que les gens
je traite un peu comme un animal
joke ça vient tout le temps comme ah
c'est drôle et c'est absurde c'est ça
mais il y a une entrevue de marque
Labrèche je pense que c'était un grand
blond avec un show sur noir ou la fin du
monde à 7h je sais pas c'est lequel
c'est deux choses mais Jean-Louis arrive
là puis là tu vois que lui dans marque
la presse dans sa tête est capable
d'aller à la même place que lui plaise
huile mais je la conversation on fait
genre ping-pong ça rebondit partout même
il passe de toutes les côtés mais les
deux suivent puis c'est haut ça flash
lui ah ça ça serait ça serait débile je
pense que on s'est essayé derrière album
qui avait sorti on avait eu même une
réponse
parce qu'il était obligé mais genre
effectivement on avait eu un refus mais
ça serait malade ça serait épique
en fait le cas qu'on a posé la question
c'est comme le nom qui m'est venu aussi
parce que entre c'est tout le temps ça
qu'on s'est dit
qui serait incroyable
[Musique]
un podcast sur l'intelligence
artificielle et qui fait le Bourdin
c'était malade mais c'est quelqu'un que
j'avais essayé à l'avoir beaucoup aussi
c'est Yoshua Benji
mondiale dans ce domaine-là
il y en a plein
mais on pourrait inviter les gens à
écrire en commentaire ce qui serait leur
éviter de rêve accessible quand même qui
voudrait qu'on reçoit
un commentaire bonne façon de terminer
le podcast merci gagne merci d'être là
merci à côté merci de votre intérêt pour
l'instant on fait pas de caisse